.
BRET?
>> Bret: STEVE, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN FOX NEWS SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST BRIT HUME.
I HEAR THIS STORY AND I JUST
THINK I HAVE HEARD THIS BEFORE.
>> BOY, HAVE WE EVER.
I MEAN, FROM THE BEGINNING,
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS AND OTHER
LEADING EXPERTS SAID THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY YOUNG
CHILDREN WERE VERY NEARLY
INVULNERABLE TO THIS DISEASE AND
YET WE CLOSED DOWN THE SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES FOR THE LONGEST
TIME WE CLOSED DOWN BUSINESSES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE PEOPLE
WORKING IN THOSE BUSINESSES WERE
YOUNG OR OLD.
ALL OF THIS IN THE NAME OF
TRYING TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THIS DISEASE AND, YET, LOOK AT
HOW MANY PEOPLE DIED FROM IT
ANYWAY.
THERE WAS THE TOTAL FAILURE ALL
ALONG THE LINE TO LOOK CAREFULLY
AT THE SIDE EFFECTS OF THE
MEASURES THAT WERE BEING TAKEN
TO FIGHT THE DISEASE.
AND THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE WAS
TERRIBLE.
I MEAN, WE KNOW ABOUT AN
EDUCATIONAL TERMS.
WE KNOW ABOUT IT IN MEDICAL
TERMS BECAUSE PEOPLE COULDN'T
GET APPOINTMENTS THAT COULDN'T
DO REGULAR HEALTHCARE,
OPERATIONS WERE POSTPONED.
CANCER SCREENINGS THAT WEREN'T
DONE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND THE
DAMAGE IS ONLY NOW BEING TOTED
UP.
PEOPLE AT LAST ARE BEGINNING TO
SEE THAT WE DID THE WRONG THING
THERE.
>> Bret: IT IS AMAIZING TO SEE.
THE STATS BEING TALKED ABOUT
OPENLY.
THEY WERE NOT FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
THE CDC ACKNOWLEDGING WHERE THIS
WAS A PUBLIC POLICY MISS IN
LARGE PART.
BUT ALSO POLITICALLY.
HERE IS PRESIDENT BIDEN TALKING
ABOUT AT THAT POINT FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS AND WHAT
HE WAS DOING ABOUT COVID IN
FLORIDA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I SAY TO THESE GOVERNORS,
PLEASE HELP.
IF YOU ARE AREN'T GOING TO HELP,
AT LEAST GET OUT OF THE WAY.
USE YOUR POWER TO SAVE LIVES.
>> Bret: THIS WAS ABOUT KIDS IN
MASKS.
THIS WAS ABOUT THE DANGER TO
KIDS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SAY WE
DIDN'T KNOW AS MUCH BACK THEN.
BUT THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO KNEW A LOT ABOUT STATS AT
THE BEGINNING.
AND, YET, IT WAS A POLITICAL,
YOU KNOW, WEAPON AT TIMES.
>> Brit: IT STARTED OUT IN SOME
RESPECTS, BRET, THE REACTION TO
COVID IS HOW PEOPLE REACTED TO
DONALD TRUMP.
IF THEY DIDN'T LIKE TRUMP, THEY
WERE ALL FOR THE MEASURES TO
FIGHT COVID AND TO BLAME HIM FOR
NOT DOING MORE AND TO BLAME
OTHERS LIKE GOVERNOR DESANTIS IN
FLORIDA WHO REGULATED WITH A
MUCH LIGHTER HAND THAN OTHER
GOVERNORS DID AND ENDED UP WITH
NO WORSE RESULTS AND HE DIDN'T
SHUT DOWN THE SCHOOLS AND HE
DIDN'T SHUT DOWN HIS STATE
NEARLY TO THE EXTENT THAT OTHERS
DID.
AND HE CAME OUT IN ABOUT THE
SAME PLACE OR BY SOME MEASURES
EACH BETTER.
COVID ALARMISTS TURNED OUT TO
HAVE THE WRONG PRESCRIPTION.
THESE VIRUSES DO SPREAD.
THE PHRASE I HEARD AGAIN AND
AGAIN DURING THIS PERIOD IS
VIRUS GOING TO VIRUS.
AND IT DID REGARDLESS OF THE
MEASURES WE TOOK.
AND THOSE MEASURES DID UNCALL DO
YOU BELIEVE DAMAGE.
>> Bret: QUICKLY, BRIT, I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T ASK YOU.
YOU ARE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
YOU HAVE THIS BIG PRIMARY COME
UP TOMORROW.
WE HAD ONE OF THE SENATE
CANDIDATES ON THE SHOW EARLIER.
A BIG DEAL THERE IN THAT STATE.
>> YEAH IT IS, BRET.
IT'S A VERY BIG DEAL BECAUSE OF
THE WORRY AMONG REPUBLICANS THIS
SEASON IS THAT THEY HAVE THIS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO REGAIN
CONTROL NOT JUST OF THE HOUSE
BUT ALSO THE SENATE AND OTHER
GOVERNORSHIPS.
GOVERNORSHIP IS UP THIS TIME
AROUND AND TRUMP HAS COME OUT
ENDORSEMENT OVER THE WEEKEND
THAT WAS DONE APPARENTLY WITHOUT
CONSULTING THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS.
THEY ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT THE GUY
HE ENDORSED.
THEY THINK HE IS TOO FAR OUT.
THAT HE COULDN'T WIN IN THE FALL
AND HAND THE STATE HOUSE
GOVERNOR'S CHAIR BACK -- WELL TO
THE DEMOCRATS TO KEEP IT AND ON
THE SENATE SIDE HE HAS ENDORSED
DR. OZ WHO MAY WELL WIN AND THE
FEAR IS THAT HE CAN'T BE ELECTED
IN THE FALL.
WANTED THE TRUMP HEAVY HAND HERE
WILL END UP HURTING THE PARTY
INSTEAD OF BRINGING IT CLOSER TO
VICTORY.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT IT
THE AGENDA NEARLY ALL OF THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE UP HERE IN BOTH
RACES IS VERY TRUMPY.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU ARE GOING TO
GET THE TRUMP AGENDA NO MATTER
HOW VOTE FOR, THE QUESTION
WHETHER THEY WILL VOT